bonsoir didier combo merci d'être avec
nous cette sûreté france doit être un
peu va-t-il utiliser on en parlait à
l'instant tous ses pouvoirs avant la fin
de son mandat à jour n'est encore longue
aux etats unis décalage horaire oblige
doit-on s'attendre à des annonces
fracassantes ces prochaines heures ou
écouter c'est difficile de le dire ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il va faire un
usage de son pouvoir de grâce comme
comme tous les présidents l'ont fait
avant lui
c'est pour ce qui concerne le trump
s'est évidemment assez contesté comme le
disait tout à l'heure votre
correspondante puisque on pense que
c'est grâce seront principalement pour
ses soutiens
et puis il faut pas oublier que si
l'accord d'aujourd'hui des grâces il y a
eu un assez grand nombre d'exécutions
capitales au niveau fédéral il y compris
l'exécution d'une femme dont on a
beaucoup entendu parler qui était
l'auteur d'un crime horrible mais qui
elle n'a pas été graciées des décisions
aussi peut-être didier combo qui peuvent
gêner joe biden on pense notamment à
cuba qui a été remis sur les listes des
dpi des terroristes par exemple y at il
d'autres décisions de ce type à
destination plus te ment de joe biden
ces décisions elles sont elles ne
peuvent être que symbolique puisque
elles prennent la forme de décret
présidentiel et que rien n'est plus
facile au président qui arrive que deux
que de prendre un décret présidentiel
contraire c'est beaucoup moins difficile
que de remettre en question une loi par
exemple et et il est certain que que joe
biden ne se privera pas de le faire il a
d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il reviendrait
sur le muslim man ce ce décret qui
interdit certains ressortissants de
certains pays musulmans d'entrée sur le
territoire
il a annoncé qu'ils aient réintégré les
accords de paris donc ce que peut faire
un train à ce stade demeure un petit peu
de l'ordre du symbolique alors donald
trump qui est de plus en plus isolé le
chef des républicains au sénat a dit ce
soir que donald trump avait provoqué je
cite la foule dans les incidents du
capitole qu'il avait abreuvé de
mensonges
qu'est ce que ça dit cette déclaration
du chef républicain au sénat que le
procès en impeachment pourrait peut-être
aboutir
oui c'est possible il y a à la chambre
des représentants il y a dix
républicains qui ont voté pour son
impeachment alors attention dit
républicain sur un petit peu plus de 200
donc ça demeure 6 à demeurer un tout
petit pourcentage
il faudrait au sénat qu'il y ait dix
sept républicains qui votent pour 7ème
pitch main sur l'ailé sur les cinquante
sénateurs républicains ce n'est pas
impossible mitch mcconnell qui est
effectivement l'ancien président du
sénat et ou leaders du sénat à effectif
c'est effectivement prononcé
pratiquement pour ceux là où elle
laissait entendre que ce serait possible
et c'est quelqu'un de très influent donc
donc ça n'est pas impossible qu'il y ait
des décisions mais n'est pas encore
certain c'est qu'ils sont l'avenir nous
le dira alors en tout cas c'est demain
que cette investiture va sonner le glas
si je peux dire pour donald trump quelle
est sa plus grande inquiétude à présent
au président sortant cette procédure
deep in chemin de la justice de son pays
je pense que la plus grande inquiétude
alors je sais pas si c'est la justice ou
les pitchouns parce que la jussie ça va
surtout concerné ses affaires privées
il a il faut pas oublier que c'est un
homme d'affaires mais il ya une chose
qui peut véritablement inquiéter c'est
que si le sénat vote lynch humaine tu es
bien ensuite il peut voter une deuxième
décision qui sera que trump il deviendra
inéligible et alors trump ne pourra pas
se présenter aux élections de 1024 il
aura beaucoup de mal à rebondir
politiquement
est-ce qu'il n'est pas déjà mort donald
trump en tout cas le tropisme est ce que
cette sortie justement avec ces
violences au capitole ne l'ont pas
définitivement rayé de la carte
politique selon vous c'est toujours
difficile de prédire l'avenir mais il
est certain que c'est une sortie qui
n'est pas glorieuse puisque cette cet
assaut sur le capitole les deux tiers
des américains le tiennent pour
responsables et et c'est quelque chose
qui est absolument inacceptable aux
états unis parce que c'est l'exécutif
qui s'en prend aux législatifs ou qui
fait pression sur le législatif et puis
c'est une remise en cause de la
démocratie donc c'est quelque chose qui
effectivement est désastreux pour
l'image de donald trump
mais attention il ya quand même une
petite minorité des américains qui
continuent de soutenir qui conduisent
soutenir ça parmi les républicains 18 %
soutiennent les s'est insurgé du
capitole donc le trump ne peut
disparaître
mais qu'en sera-t-il du tropisme qu'en
sera-t-il ce mouvement social qui l'a
porté au pouvoir
il sait ce qui sait ce que l'avenir nous
dira alors pour joe biden en tout cas
les choses deviennent
sérieuse il ne saura plus l'opposant
mais le président aux affaires
à quoi doit-on s'attendre les premières
semaines les premiers mois alors la
majorité dont dispose byden à la chambre
des représentants et au sénat est très
faible donc au point de vue législatif
ça va être malgré tout assez difficile
même s'il a une majorité les démocrates
ne vote pas forcément systématiquement
d'un bloc est un des enjeux
ça va être le passage de la loi sur la
natte de la naturalisation d'un grand
nombre d'immigrants clandestins
ça c'est quelque chose qu'il veut mettre
rang en route assez rapidement l'autre
loi qu'il voudra mettre en route c'est
une loi de soutien à l'économie à la
suite de la pandémie au vide et donc il
y aura au moins ces deux textes qui
seront un grand enjeu
au vu du faso c'est face au lou sénat et
à la chambre des représentants avec
malheureusement comme dans tous les pays
du monde un boulet si j'ose dire à la
jambe
l'épidémie de covin dont il s'est fait
une priorité avec des chiffres qui
flambe un des nombreux records de
contamination et de décès encore aux
états unis oui il s'est fait élire entre
autres sur le l'inaction de donald trump
face au co vider sont ceux son peu
d'intérêt pour la question et les mêmes
sont c'est sa façon de nier l'importance
du virus sa façon de montrer comment
lui-même l'avait su remonter et donc
maintenant bailon il va être au pied du
mur parce que il va se trouver face à
cette épidémie qu'il ne semble pas
faiblir
on entend parler de nouveaux variants la
difficulté de mettre en place la
vaccination est là là on va le voir au
pied du mur et ça risque d'être assez
compliqué justement à l'instant on
apprend que les états unis ont franchi
la barre des 400 mille morts liés au co
vie dans les chiffres ne parviennent de
l'université johns hopkins merci à vous
disiez combo d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur notre antenne